When I want to
learn something new,
I'll dive right in and start
hacking something together
using my intuition
and Stack Overflow.
I want to invest a couple of
hours getting a feel for how
things work without worrying
too much about the right way
to do it.
So if all I want to do is
build an Android app that
will automatically turn on
my internet connected lights
when I get close to
my house, do I really
need to use Fragments,
Services, and Intent Receivers?
For me, step one is
getting something
to work, a proof of concept
that what I want to do
is even possible.
It's throwaway code that
generally no one will ever see,
but it'll get me excited
enough to sit down and invest
the time required to
build something real.
Developing real apps for
mobile is complicated.
So as a developer
advocate, I worry
that we spend so much
time encouraging beginners
to develop the right
way that folks like
me will get frustrated
before they experience
the thrill of getting
something cool to work.
So before looking at why we
can't simply do everything
within a single Activity, let's
go ahead and build a prototype
that does exactly that.
So we got the main Activity.
This is going to
be our main form.
We've got nothing in
here at the moment.
So this is our base layout.
We have text, hello world.
So we can keep this
TextView, because this
is where we're going to stick
our location results so we
can see what happens as we're
getting location updates.
We want to give an ID.
So we're going to call
this location text.
So now we're able
to get access to it.
And we can change the text.
We don't want that
to be hello world.
We want this to show allocation.
So I'm just going to set
this to none received.
So let's find a button.
Drag that on here.
I'm going to put it underneath.
And I'm going to change the
text here to location on.
And I'm going to
grab another button.
Put it next to the first button.
And I'm going to call
this one location off.
I'm going to drop it underneath.
Now I have a really
simple layout,
which is going to let us turn
the LocationManager on and off.
So we're going to need to make
sure both of these buttons
have IDs as well so we
can get access to them.
And ID is button on.
And this one is going
to be button off.
And we're going to change our
text ID as well so that it's
consistent with the others.
And this will be
text edit location.
Now we're going to flip
back to the main Activity.
Now we know that we
have an off button,
now we have an EditText.
And we're also going to want
a LocationManager, which
is what I'm going to
use to get location
updates-- LocationManager.
And then we're going to want
to use the on button to enable
our location updates.
So we'll assign a
new onClickListener,
and request location
updates from there
using the LocationManager.
And then we will have
something to turn off
the LocationListener.
So we'll do the same
thing for the off button.
Well fist, we know this is
a TextView, not an EditText.
Let's go ahead and create
these values in the meantime.
It's going to be 10 seconds.
Our distance, one meter.
Now for our
provider, we're going
to use the
LocationManager again.
Get best provider
criteria, which is enabled.
And in fact we're going to go
ahead and move that in here.
Really the only
thing that matters
here is whether it's coarse
or fine, where coarse
is going to give you
a better battery life,
and finger is going to
give you higher accuracy.
Really you're just choosing
between using the GPS
or using the Wi-Fi.
All right, so now all
we need is a listener.
We could do that
in line as well,
but we're going to
do that out here.
So that's right.
We're going to need to have
our TextView have a scope
that we can actually
access here.
So let's bring it
outside of our onCreate.
And onLocationChanged, we're
going to set our location text.
Eventually we're going
to want to update this.
For now, we just want to see
it updating as the application
changes come in.
If our LocationProvider
is disabled,
we want to update the
text to say as much.
In the real world, you're going
to want to do something there,
which is most likely find a
different LocationProvider
to use.
This is usually the GPS got
turned off for some reason
but again for our
purposes, we just
want to be able to
see what is happening.
So if we come down
here, we can see
something is underlined in red.
So what's going on here?
And we need to get the
right access permissions
to be able to get fine location.
So let's do that.
Add permissions
for fine location.
All right, so what
we're seeing here
is actually the new
permission model for M,
where we need to ask
for that fine location
at the time at which
it's requested.
Let's make this a little
bit more readable.
All right, so this is
going to check to make sure
we have permission, whether
it be fine or coarse,
depending on what kind
of activity provider
we are requesting.
In this case it's
going to be fine.
But we may change that.
And so this is going to
handle both of those cases.
And what it's
suggesting we do here
is if that isn't the case, that
we call request permissions.
And that will then
pop up a dialog
asking the user if they are
going to allow us to use it.
So we're going to
need to override
this method if the user
does allow us the permission
to use a location.
Now here we're going to want to
enable our location updates--
updates.
Which of course doesn't
yet exist, so let's
put that in here as
well, which means we're
going to want to call it here.
And of course that means we
need to move our LocationManager
to a different scope.
Let's put him up here as well.
And we'll take their advice.
And we're going to call
request permission here.
And we're going to move
this down here as well.
minTime, minDistance
needs to get moved also.
This gets us far
enough that we're
able to see whether or not
our location call works.
So let me fire up the emulator
and see what that looks like.
Let's start by
turning location on.
So this is the permission.
Let's me say allow.
So let's go with location.
And let's send it.
So you can see the updates
coming through there.
We turn location off.
And nothing happens.
Now of course for our
testing, we really
like to see all of
these instantly.
So why don't we go
back into our code
and change the update rates.
So this should get us
all updates all the time.
So now I'm going to
tidy up a little bit
and move a few things around.
My real goal here is just to
separate all the boilerplate
code like listeners, click
handlers, and permission checks
from my app and business logic.
This separation is also going
to make it easier for me
later when I need to move and
refactor it and pull it out
of this monolithic Activity
into the appropriate services
and intent receivers.
Ideally I want to be
able see all the code
I'm going to be adjusting
and changing regularly
on the same screen.
Now we know the
next thing which we
need to do, because we
know that we are going
to want to react to
the location changing,
because the ultimate
goal here is,
once we get within a certain
distance of our house,
is to turn on the lights.
So we're going to need at
least one more method, which
is going to turn on the lights.
And we're going
to call that here.
OK, so we need to
find out whether we
are within a set distance.
So we'll probably want to have
ways to set all that in our UI.
But for now, let's just
go and make some statics.
So we're going to need to know
how far our current location is
from our home location.
So we can do that by
saying location.distanceTo.
And we can say here
our home location,
which means we're going to
need to have a home location.
So let's do that.
Let's cheat, do that manually.
Explicitly set the
latitude and longitude.
So neither of these exist.
Oops, neither of these exist.
I'm going to interrupt myself
here to point something else.
You may have noticed that I'm
setting the longitude twice
and never sitting the latitude.
That's something I didn't
notice at the time,
and it's going to cause
me problems later.
I'm going to go with
Google's home location, which
I will grab.
So we have a distance,
which is the distance
from your current location
to the home location.
If it's less than
a turn on distance,
which we've sent
to 10 meters, then
toggle the lights on, which
is happening down here.
So we know that we're going
to want to turn the lights on
and off and that
this is going to be
a command over the interwebs.
We can't actually--
we're not allowed
to access the internet
on the main thread.
So we're going to have to move
it into a background thread.
So we're going to do that by
creating an AsyncTask, which
creates some simple
handlers for us
to make this life a
little bit easier.
Again, like I said, not
the right approach to this.
Much better ways using Services.
But this is an easy way
for us to get started,
AsyncTask lets you move a
task into the background,
optionally reporting progress
while it's being executed,
and then synchronizing
the UI thread
when that task is complete.
We can choose to pass parameters
and optionally return a value
from the background task.
Here we're going to
use void to specify
that we don't want
to use any parameters
or return any values.
I'm going to have an API or
OS call to make that happen.
But let's have a look.
We want to be able to have a
way of finding out that this
is actually happening.
Why don't we return a Boolean.
So now we're going to get a
return from the background
task telling us whether we've
turned the lights on or off.
And we're going to want
to override onPostExecute,
which is what gets called
once the background task has
finished.
And here we get the
Boolean returned to us.
And we'll use a Toast
here, because this is now
synchronized to the UI thread.
So the onPostExecute is
synchronized to your UI thread.
So we can do things like this.
All right, let's have
a look at what that
looks like in the emulator.
So why don't we just go ahead
and paste in the specific lat
and long for home.
Now what we're expecting
to happen is I hit send.
And we should get a Toast
that tells us that we
have turned the lights on.
That blank look
corresponds to something
on the inside that
looks a lot like this.
Notice the lat-long
value has changed.
But I was expecting a
Toast, and there isn't one.
You and I know that's because
I set the home location
longitude to its latitude,
and it's latitude to zero.
At the time I didn't
know if the problem was
my asynchronous code,
the Toast, or something
related to the distance
from home calculation.
I knew the lat-long
coming in was correct,
so I decided to update the UI
to show my current distance
from home instead.
That will be useful
for debugging
and give me a clue as
to what was going wrong.
So now that we have
all of this, rather
than displaying the
latitude-longitude,
which doesn't really
make mean anything.
We know what that does now.
So what we're
going to do instead
is update our text string
to show the distance
so we can see as we're getting
closer, because that's really
the critical part that
we want to have now.
So we're getting a distance now.
Perfect.
Eventually I try plugging in
the values for my home location
at the Googleplex.
And the distance result
is not what I expected.
So now I know the problem
is the distance calculation.
I spent several minutes
going down some blind alleys.
I'm pretty convinced I'm
transposing lats and longs
somewhere.
But eventually I see what's
right in front of me.
All right, so you can see I've
set both latitude and longitude
to the same value.
Now we are much closer-- much
closer to our house-- in fact,
less than a meter
away, which you'd
hope given that it's
the right value.
But wait, it's that face again.
I know my distance is right,
but there's still no Toast.
Now I'm annoyed.
What the [BLEEP]?
I set some break points
and stepped through this
a couple of times.
Looks like I'm getting the
right values at the right time.
The right code is getting
executed, but still no Toast.
Maybe I can't call a Toast
from within AsyncTask.
Maybe I'm sending in the
wrong context to the Toast.
Eventually I decide
to take a look
at why the little red light
bulb is highlighting my code.
And of course you're going
to want to show your Toast.
All right, so there you go.
That all works as you
would expect it to.
So we've got an app that's
a pretty reasonable proof
of concept that it's at least
possible to do what we want,
automatically turn on our
internet connected lights
when we get close to home.
This screencast represents about
two hours of real time coding.
Most of what's being trimmed
is me thinking or going down
wrong alleys when debugging,
waiting for emulators
to spin up, or trying
to remember which
API calls I should be making.
Now if you're an experienced
Android developer,
you're probably getting
ready to throw something
through your screen
right about now.
And if you've done even a
little Android training,
you're either angry or
confused, and rightly so.
While this code will
technically work,
it does a lot more
wrong than it does
right, which is why you
typically don't show people
your throw away prototype.
As you can see from
these red circles,
each representing
code that either
doesn't belong in an
Activity or has been replaced
with a new and
better API, or both,
not much of what we've
written is going to be kept.
And that's ignoring
even basic things
like how to handle
Activity life cycle events
and potentially leaking memory
through our LocationListener
and AsyncTask implementations.
Now turning this
into a real app is
where the complexity comes in.
Later videos in the
"Pivotal" series
will dive into each of
these issues in detail.
But let's take a quick look at
what a better structure might
look like.
For starters, in a lot of
other platform paradigms,
that main form is synonymous
with the app itself.
And that's not the
case in Android.
The only thing that should
be in the Activity is the UI.
Anything else, like requesting
and receiving location updates,
or making internet API calls,
needs to be moved elsewhere.
So a better
architecture is to have
an Activity for the UI combined
with Services to provide
tasks when the UI is invisible,
and an Intent receiver
to react to context changes
even if the app isn't running.
Ideally this app would be
almost entirely autonomous.
You do need a UI to turn it
on, to set a home location.
And the rest will
then be automatic.
You don't need to
use Fragments here,
but encapsulating that
UI logic into Fragments
will make it easier to build
out more complex UI navigation
patterns later.
Apps without visible activities
get killed by the runtime,
so if we want to get continuous
location updates when another
is in the foreground,
you'll need
a Service to keep it alive.
Within that Service
we can either
trigger the constant
location updates
as we do in that prototype,
or we can be more efficient
and use the geofencing APIs
available from Google Play
services rather than
constantly calculating
the distance from home.
Using that API, we may not
even need this Service.
The light control
API calls absolutely
need to be in a Service.
All internet lookups need to
be moved out of Activities,
and using a service will
ensure it can complete
before the app is killed.
Finally, we want to move
our LocationListener out
of the Activity and listen
for location change Intents
from within its own Intent
receiver class, which
we'll register in the manifest.
We do this so that
even if the app is
being killed by the
runtime, we will still
receive location updates.
The app will actually
be started specifically
so that it can receive these
location change Intents.
And then they can start
the lighting service,
if that's necessary.
So after a couple of hours,
we have a working prototype
and the first pass of a
more robust architecture,
a good starting point to
start hacking away in earnest.
It's important to understand
the right way to build apps,
but that shouldn't get
in the way of hacking
and slashing your way
to a proof of concept
before you begin in earnest.
If you found this
interesting, keep an eye
out for my new show,
"Pivotal," where
I'll be screencasting
the process of creating
and upgrading a full location
and context based app
using the best
practices and patterns
that I started describing here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]